I think it works marvelously okay
sidekick that's that's the Prince Eddie
Murphy and then semi I think semi was
the name of his his loyal sidekick right
a sidekick is not as skilled as the hero
but has certain skills to offer remains
completely loyal as semi does the
sidekick is always loyal does not die
unless it's a formal tragedy yeah then
like King Lear and the fool yeah
provides counsel and conflict yes often
same-sex but not always there are some
very interesting relationships sidekick
relationships that are opposite sex
relationships and can echo a hero's
romance with a comedic one now then here
are some successful sidekicks Dory in
Finding Nemo did see Dory the forgetful
one she is a classic classic sidekick
rusty Ryan in Ocean's eleven also a
classic it's against sometimes casting
throws you off because he's a star
playing the part but it's still the role
and function in the story is that's a
sidekick Ellie burr in insomnia how many
of you have seen insomnia a few okay
yeah it is it's really terrific in many
many ways and it's got relationships
that are worth taking a look at
especially this one between Ellie burr
and her hero so I would put it on the
list just don't view it when you're
depressed okay Albert of course in hitch
Oda Mae brown in ghost
remember how wonderfully charming that
relationship was she becomes the medium
through which the dead guy can speak to
his living girlfriend they weren't
married with it I don't think so I think
was a girlfriend and she's perfect and
she's hilarious
and Peter brand and so forth okay I have
picked also here an opposite-sex a
sidekick I want you to see how this
works - this is not the obvious one of
the obvious ones okay and this is out of
Inception and it's Ariadne remember he
Cobb I'm assuming most of you have seen
this picture yes
has anybody not seen it just okay mm-hmm
okay put it on the list
he has taken he's putting together a
team because he needs to enter a CEOs
dreams and fool him into changing his
mind about something extremely important
it's rather intellectual but physically
it works visually it works very very
well in the movies extraordinary movie
actually and she is the architect he has
hired and brought in so she goes back
she's curious about her hero here
because he's acting kind of funny kind
of strange she can tell that there's
something going on inside of him that
she really thinks she needs to know
about finds Cobb hooked to the dream
machine and she joins him she hooks
herself up to the same dream their
upcoming job is dangerous so she needs
to know more about Cobbs troubled dreams
what is he hiding and then she finds
herself wakes up in the dream and finds
herself descending in this decrepit
wonderful old elevator descending into
Cobbs dark psyche and she finds him in a
room of a house somewhere speaking and
low low tones low personal tones with a
woman she doesn't yet know that this is
small and that this is this is his dead
wife all is dead and the only place she
still exists is in Cobbs memory and
dreams
and but all of a sudden there's a
there's another person in the dream so
mall and Cobb are startled that they're
with somebody
and they see they're not alone Cobb runs
over you know he's got to get her out of
there as quickly as he can I'd get
Ariadne out of there he says what are
you doing here this has nothing to do
with you and she retorts like a good
sidekick would it has everything to do
with me you've asked me to share dreams
with you I need to go implication I need
to know what the heck is going on in
here well I guess I jumped the gun I
need to know what's going on with you
yes there are things you should know
he's not always you know antagonistic
towards his sidekick that is not the
nature of the hero sidekick relationship
he knows he's got a show or something
and let her in on something so Cobb
takes her deeper into his dream world he
is willing to reveal parts of his
troubled psyche to his sidekick he takes
her to his home at another time and he
shows her his home takes her down the
hall and into his home and shows him her
to his two children that he longs more
than anything to return to that's his
goal actually but the children never
quite turned to me I can never see their
faces he confesses he's always denied
fulfillment of being with them and
holding them and having them see him -
and Ariadne says these aren't dreams
they're memories and you told me never
to use memories see she's on this stuff
she's learning she's putting two and two
together
Ariadne slips back into the elevator
without Cobb and pushes the basement
button she must find out what haunts
Cobb the most so at the very bottom in
the basement of things that he protects
about himself she finds his darkest
memory is about a hotel suite where
furniture has been
Ashtyn thrown thrown around like it been
a big fight or something like that and
then she noticed over on the on the
couch is the same woman that she saw
before
this is Mall this is Cobbs dead wife
remembered in his memories and dreams
mall hisses you don't belong here the
sidekick finds herself trying to
understand the nature of the hero's
wound do you know what it is to be a
lover to behalf of a hole and and
Ariadne is just kind of overwhelmed by
at all it's just no and what she does
not see it at least it's shot in a way
that she does not see that mall leans
over basically and picks up a weapon a
broken a broken wineglass Cobb arrives
pulls Ariadne back into the elevator
just in time because Maul attacks her
Maul attacks and screams you promised
you promised and she's talking to Cobb
obviously he has promised her something
Ariadne now understands that Maul could
show up in their dream at any time with
the power to kill people she insists the
other members of the team need to be
told
okay I've had to skip over a whole lot
of stuff but what she is doing the
absorption of information about her hero
how she pushes back on her hero as he
tries to cover things up forcing him to
deal with the troubling stuff inside
this is classic this is classic sidekick
stuff and there is no no hint of
anything romantic between the two of
them that would that would ruin the
whole sidekick thing that's not an issue
here that would that would change the
dynamic and it just wouldn't work in
this case the sidekick not as skilled as
the hero that is true here remains
completely loyal that is absolutely true
of her does not die
actually that is true also and by the
end provides counsel and conflict for
the hero exactly what she does
usually same-sex but not always and can
echo a hero's romance with a comedic one
of her own in that case that is
irrelevant but that is how she fits into
that category